Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now I've got a bunch of things to show for you,
I've been setting this up for about an hour and a half,
and admittedly I had to use console commands,
but you'll see why, because there was no alternative for what I was doing.
But I needed to start here, uh, in the Grand Reef,
because they did an expansion of the Grand Reef,
and they added quite a few new things.
Mostly environmental, but there actually is a new
creature over here, which I don't remember where I was out here.
The reason, uh, I'm starting here is because I didn't even
know about this until I came out here, because I came
out to get the new nuclear reactor fragments,
and I just got the last one, so I have the nuclear reactor,
which I'm going to build in my... new base! Which you guys
are gonna see, in a little bit.
It-it-it's not there yet, that's gonna be towards the end of the episode.
But what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna show you this first,
I'm gonna head back to my main base,
gather a few more supplies, and then I'm gonna go
down-- let's see... I've got an- I've also got a compass now
so I can actually see where I'm orienting, and I believe I
need to go to the North.
Oh yeah, and if you see all those pulsating things down there,
don't worry about that yet, we're gonna get to that later.
But you may notice that the symbol is actually different,
because in this episode I'm gonna show you, uh,
the exosuit, which actually isn't a part of this update,
but that's why I had to use console commands,
is because the exosuit is a new thing that allows for very, very, very deep sea exploration,
up to 1700 meters. Now to get that, you need a lot of materials, and I might have to use some more
console commands to get them, because you're not technically supposed to be able to even get the exosuit.
But it's fully animated, and it's for the most part pretty much working correctly,
it's not 100% but it's good enough for our purposes, and
our purposes are just exploring the cool new stuff that's available around here.
But first, I gotta find these goddamn things.
I'm not even just try to spoil it before I get there,
because they're really cool to see and when I stumbled across them it was like,
"What the hell happened to you? What's wrong with you?"
Like something ripped out of Half-Life 2 and put into this game.
It's really cool. But let me see it.
Oh and I need to gather some of this stuff.
This is, uh, this is uraninite. Uraninite? Uran- uranininite?
A highly radioactive and... uh.. interesting material.
That's what's gonna be used for the nuclear reactor,
so I wanna gather up some of it before I go out there,
because in the Grand Reef I believe it's the only place for this stuff.
Oh this is so-- there it is! Hi buddy! How you doing?
Oh man, look at him. You know what I mean by,  it looks like it was ripped out of Half-Life 2,
it looks like the striders, and I believe, I'm not 100% sure about this,
I did scan one, I believe it was called, like, the Ground Strider,
and they're so cool! They're just waving their arms like they're partying all night long, I love 'em to death,
and if you get close to 'em they kick you! Just like this!
Hey come on! Kick me! Kick me! I want you to do it! Come on!
Hey what are you doing? What are you doing? Bonk!
Does that not bother you? There he goes. Wait, he's gonna do it, he goin' do it, oh shit he about to do it!
No he not gonna do it. Why doesn't he wanna kick me?
Maybe it's because I'm not outside of my ship. Let me do this.
Hey you gonna kick me buddy? Ooh I'm low on health, careful about that.
Hey. Hey! You're ugly! You're ugly and no one likes you!
No? Huh? Usually they're animated before, I swear.
Ugh, your mouth is so bizarre. But he's got a tiny little smile up there, that's adorable.
Alright, fine then, but there's a whole herd of them is what the weird-- oh, also,
I finally, uh, I finally named my seamoth Bubblebutt, cause I just love that name,
and I got him colorized so that he's all customized over there.
So I got the NopeBoat and I got Bubblebutt, but either way that's what I wanted to show you,
and they got his whole, like uh,
this whole area here is all built up and different, and if I actually go into this cave system here,
it's like... it's like a grand archway and you can't see much of it at night right now, but
it-it-it's a really cool grand archway that you can barely see the edges of over there, and there's some
bioluminescent stuff on the outskirts of it, you can barely see it over there but it's like a huge,
like, cavernous tunnel, and I don't know what the purpose of it is, in fact I think it might have been
at one point, like developed or bored through by a giant creature, who knows.
Cause there are some giant creatures over here. Hi buddy! Hey! Hi friend, how you doing? Bonk!
Sorry about that. Sorry friend-- I don't even know if these things are killable yet, but they exist,
and they are things. But either way, gotta get back to uh, I gotta get back to my main base over there.
So the next thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna pause, I'm gonna come back when I'm over there,
there's another uraninite. So let me get that, and then I'll see ya at my base. Yay!
Oh and if it wasn't obvious I built another seamoth. See I've been playing for a long time before this
particular episode because I wanted to make sure that everything I had was in working order so that
you guys wouldn't be incredibly disappointed for me, and boy I've got some surprising things to show you,
but not until I get done with this and not until I get everything that I got going on here.
And, um, it's pretty cool but first thing I gotta read the names, but thank you everybody who commented
down below, and I put them on the lockers over here! So there's Ned821, who made fun of my inability
to get my seamoth back into my cyclops.
There's LinusBur who made fun of me and said that if I
was swimming around I'd probably drown, so thank you very much.
And then there's, oh, TigressFoxy, uh, I wrote these down,
I don't have them anymore, but TigressFoxy who gave the terrifying idea
that that skeleton down in the Lost River,
like maybe it didn't die of natural causes.
Maybe it was killed by something even bigger, and that's a horrifying thought,
but there can't have just been one! If I know anything about creatures and their mommies and daddies,
it had to have been birthed or hatched at some point, and there probably was something bigger.
And then Kasuten C, uh, who said something very, very useful
and educational,
and it was probably game-changing and probably gonna make everything wonderful for me
throughout the rest of the game, but I can't remember what it was right now!
So I'm just gonna drift through as if everything is fine.
But anyway, uh, there are three new things that I want to show you
Actually they're not even new. They've been around forever
And, oh damn it, I think I left it in my other base, which I'm gonna show you
Okay, um, I built them
But I gotta spawn em in now so give me two seconds here
Okay, so I got em- so this...
is the Stasis Rifle. Which I got the plans for, in like, the third episode of this entire series
I just never used it. I never made it, I never built it,
but, what's cool about this, and it's just turning daytime so this is convenient, is-
Oop, shit, sorry. Ignore that! Ignore that.
What you do is you hold it down, you charge it up,  you fire this thing out,
and it creates a stasis bubble! And anything that goes in this, gets stopped in its tracks.
Even the Reaper Leviathan can be stopped by this thing.
Admittedly only for a short period of time, and I'm not 100% sure how long that is?
But it will stop it. So what I'm gonna do is, to show this off I'm gonna go over here,
uh, to these smaller, NOT Reaper Leviathans first, and then I'm gonna go over to the Reaper Leviathan because, I'm- eh,
my second base is near another one, and it's very dangerous and I'm probably gonna die from it... Oh.
Nah, this'll do! A little Airsack. It's a perfect candidate for what I'm about to unleash.
WABOOSHKY!
Oh no... you can't move, can ya? Oh, ya can't move, CAN YA!? Perfect candidate for my new device,
which is a Propulsion Cannon. And the Propulsion cannon is another object that I've had forever and I've just never built, does this:
WABOOM!
Sorry Airs- oh god, oho god, oh god! The explosion of blood!
Oh, no, is that it? Is that's its- is that is dead corpse? Aw geez.
Wha- *laughing* oh, look at my waggly fingers! I'm gon waggle ya! Oh geez.
"Oxygen, I forgot that's something I need." -Markiplier, 2016
But the propulsion cannon, it grabs up objects, and it can even rip limestone offa the sea walls,
and uh, it allows you to grab 'em... or, fire 'em.
BOOM!
Which is awfully convenient. And then there's this other thing, called the REpulsion Cannon, which just propels things.
Now, I don't know what it can propel a maximum of? The Propulsion Cannon can only grab small objects,
but this can push anything.
HA-BOUM!
And it can push it FAR. And I don't know if it works on a Reaper Leviathan, but I know it works on- some bigger fish?
Like... gimme two seconds here. To get over to the thing.
Liiiiike... man it's been forever. Oh, how I miss you, safe shallows!
*Blows kisses*
I've gone into dangerous territory and I may never return! But I love you!!! I love all of you. (Love you too Mark)
Come on, give me something to repulse.
Repulse with my horrifically ugly face.
Where are you?!
Where'd it go? Where is he? Where are those guys?
Did I- did I farm them all to death by searching for their teeth? Good God.
They seem to be gone.
Well, I probably should have taken my seamoth out anyway.
Cause Bubblebutt would have been a lot faster about this stuff but oh well.
Alright, and we're gonna get to that in a second,
everyone just ignore that down there, that's not important right now;
ignore the fact that my cyclops is currently parked 900 meters below the sea floor.
Everyone ignore that, you don't need to worry about it, it's not something you need to worry about right now.
Okay, so, considering I can't exactly test this repulsion cannon on any of the fauna down here
in the Creepvine Forest, what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna test it
on a Reaper Leviathan because why the hell not?
I may live and die, but I'll know that I'll be fine,
I guess, maybe, probably not going to be fine.
Where did I go? I went far out, geez. Where am I?
Where am I?!
Where the fuck am I? Oh, there I am, okay.
Alright, but either way those are the guns, I've got some uraninite
and ignore that, don't mind that thing,
that's not important right now, that's not important, don't worry about it, it's fine.
Everybody, everybody stop panicking, it's fine.
Okay, so I think I got everything that I need down here, so now
it's time to go to my second base! And to do that, I gotta head North.
Nope, no, that's not North, that's North.
I gotta head a bit to the North and go past this mushroom forest here,
uh, because down this mushroom forest is a familiar place that we've been to a few times before.
At the heart of Subnautica.
Wait, (more menacingly) at the heart of Subnautica,
in the deepest parts of the ocean, where only death awaits us!
There lies some-- damn it-- there lies something!
Deeper and darker than anything we could possibly imagine.
I need to move elsewhere. But if I can find it,
but before I can find it I, I'll, I'm gonna be running into, uh,
into a Reaper Leviathan because the Reaper Leviathan guards the entrance to the inactive lava zone,
and, uh, that's where we're headed, there have been some updates down there, and I know this
because I've been down there before this episode started, and that's where I built my new base,
and that's why I had to use console commands, like,
I, I don't like to use 'em, but I wouldn't have been able to haul all the material that I needed all the way down there,
uh, to be able build that thing, sorry about that, oh geez,
oh geez, okay, so that's the entrance.
The big gaping black hole in the bottom of the ocean,
but somewhere, around here,
is a garsh darn goddamn Reaper Leviathan.
Where the furr did you go?
Hello? I, I know there's one around here,
and it shouldn't be this hard to spot 'em. What is that?
Oh geez, oh okay, I thought that was another chasm into the darkness!
Okay, so there's
usually, where's that ship? 'Cause it's usually by the ship,
the crashed ship.
Somewhere around here. I thought I woulda heard it by now.
Maybe it wandered off. Maybe it's never gonna bother me again.
Maybe I'm finally free of its tyrannical grip.
Uuh, oh! Hey, how's it going? Okay, oh god.
Uh, alright.
Alright! Whoa, what the fuck?
Ow!
Jesus Criminy Christmas, do I have a med kit-- thank goodness! Good golly! Alright.
Whoo, let me drink some water.
Let me, I got a Cured Oculus, alrighty.
Whoo! I wanted to eat a last meal before I go after this bitch.
Alright, so whoowhowho. Whookay.
Alright, okay, here we go! Oh geez! Oh god!
Alright, charge up, charge up!
Bam! Oh that's not far, why, how, how did it do that?
Ahh, hey! No, don't you don't. No you don't! Don't- don't even think about it brah.
Okay, so, damn it I'm wasting all my power!
What is that? What is that? Okay.
So the thing about this is, ah goddamn it, I'm running out of oxygen.
Okay, so I gotta get a little closer, which isn't very happy for me,
I don't want to lose Bubblebutt over here. I really don't want to lose Bubblebutt,
but I gotta get closer to this thing. Ooh god, oh geez, oh it spotted me!
Ow! Oh geez x4, BAM! Oh shit, how? Why?
BAM! Oh shit, you gotta hit in the head!
You gotta get a head shot! Ah geez, oh it's after that sand shark, oh that poor little bitch.
Oh geez, oh gosh. Oh gosh, c'mere!
Goddammit, just c'mere! Bam! 'Kay that guy's getting stasis-ed.
Oh geez.
Bam! Oh shit. Okay, we're fine. Get over here you son of an ass!
Ah geez, ah geez, ah gosh!
Oh man, I, I didn't think it would be this hard to get his attention.
He usually is very adamant about getting- ooh. Eh, eh, that's, really close.
Oh geez oh geez oh geez oh geez-
WH-BAM!
YES! Look at that! I got you, bitch! Oh, I'm gonna do this again just in case...
I gotta full charge it... Woah, okay.
Woah. But look at that! Oh, not so tough now, Bubba! Ain'tcha?
Oh, you're not so tough now! HUH!? That's what I thought.
I don't know how long this lasts, but I'm gonna overcompensate. Do it again...
BAYUM!
Okay. Man, he is not happy. *mockingly* He's mayud. Oh look at 'em, he's so mayud. Oh he's the mayudest- okay.
This is where things get weird! Imma try this:
HABUM!
OH! It booshed 'em! Oh, it booshed 'em outta the bubble. Shit, but it booshed 'em!
♪ Oh, I can boosh you! ♪
You ain't so tough now! Huh!? I mean you're still pretty tough and you're probably gonna kill me, but I'm gonna boosh the shit outta ya.
I'mhna- I'm gonna waggly-finger ya! Ooh, my Propulsion Cannon's gonna get all ~waggly~ on ya!
Get over here! Lil' BITCH! HUH!? LIL' BITCH-BABY!? LIL' BITCH-BABY WANNA FIGHT ME!?
With your mmmmmuscle definition down the side o' ya. Alright, that's right, run away.
Run away like a little baby! Oh shit. Heh, I'm runnin' away like a little baby.
Okay. Oh- he mayud! He ma- AH!
He mad! Oh no! My SeaMoth! Get- get rid of it. Hey!
Let it go! Let it go! Get outta here! Get outta here!!!
GET OUTTA HERE!
You're gonna get stasis'd.
Hrrrrreeeummm
BOINK!
Oh shit.
Okay, let me get a full charge on 'em so I can get away...
*mockingly* Aaaand, mayud! Oh he's so mayud. Oh he ma- uh oh.
My SeaM- uh oh. Uh oh! My SeaMoth is caught in the bubble! *laughing* Oh god, I'm caught in the stasis bubble!
OH, WHAT HAVE I DONE!? Oh, I fucked up. I fucked up! I taunted... I taunted too much.
I was playing with fire. Okay, good, I'm free. Woo! Alright. You have fun there.
You have fun baby-boo! I'll leave you alone now.
Oh, he was mayud. Oh he gon' be mayud. Oh he's so mayud.
Alright, so where am I? I got a little disoriented over here. But I thiiiiiink- okay, East, North...
I need to go... not North, I need to go East.
Okay. Ugh... Man that was... That was temptin' fate, but that was fun! I did it. I did okay!
Okay so the black hole entrance should be... somewhere to the left, over heerrrrrrre.
Is that it, or is that just an unloaded area? I have a funny feeling- yeah, it was just an unloaded area.
So it'd just be on the second ridge. Hoo! Anyway!
Those are-- it works! So that's how you do that! So I don't have to be so scareedd.
I don't wanna be scareedd at everything in the ocean anymore. I've got guns now! Ooh.
Oh and also! I wanted to mention, um- some of you may have been confused by the fact my SeaMoth can currently go down to 1000 meters because they removed that.
What I did, um, I have the legacy version of the uh, euugh. I hate this, I hate going into this. Still scary even though I've been down here a couple times now.
But uh, I've got the legacy version of the, uh, SeaMoth pressure compensator? It's the old version, which allows it to go down to 1000 meters.
Um... but, what I'm gonna do when I get down there is I'm gonna make the new version of it, which... is different? Oh.
Wait, am I goin' the right way? This doesn't seem r- THIS doesn't seem right- naw, that's not the right way. Okay.
I- I'm gonna make the new version of it, which works with the exosuit, which is gonna allow me... to do even more when I go down there.
But first, I gotta find my way back here, 'cause it's kind of a... It's kind of a labyrinthian maze? I think this is the entrance over here.
And I'm pretty sure I just hang rights... all the way down here.
See, but you can see they actually... they actually modified the inactive lava zone down here because you can see that the walls aren't just that weird... bubbly poopy texture?
And I appreciate a good bubbly poopy texture but... frankly, I'm a little bit... happy that it's nice and actually looks like underwater sea floor now.
Be-uh, for some respect. I don't know what underwater sea floor looks like but probably not this repeated texture cavernous tunnel.
Alright. Down we go! Oh geez.
Oh, what's that in the distance you see? Oh-ho, could it be...
A HIDDEN UNDERWATER BASE!?
It definitely could be, and I think I actually went a different way down here, but uh, this is terrifying?
Because... you'll see that this is my base, and I built it up pretty good, but we're at 923 meters.
And I built it onto the precipice into the deeper, deeper depths. Like, if you see the outline of what's down there...
It ain't good. And, the only thing! The only thing that can go down there... Not even my cyclops, which is...
Where's- where the frick did my Cyclo- I think it's up... er-
Where'd my Cyclops go?
Where'd the Nopeboat go?
Who t- Who took my Nopeboat!?
Oh- Oh there it is, okay, there it is. There's my Nopeboat! 'Kay, there's the Cyclops.
And here's my base, but, what's down below, the Cyclops can't even get to. So I have to pop out real quick here.
*thunk*
And then imma- Dammit! I keep running- Oh, why am I doing this, I could just... I, I built...
I built a Moonpool down here, which is completely illogical- ah, god, look at that
It's so deep! *acting scared* It's so deep! Eeeeh!
Okay. So anyway... goin' in here.
BOOPITY-BOOP!
Welcome aboard. So, in here... I've got a little base, and the problem with building a base down here...
And I've got convenient illumination from these exosuits out there, which we're gonna get to... later.
Probably in the next episode, because I don't have enough time for this one, but I'm just gonna show ya-
The only problem with building a base down here is you don't have any natural sunlight, so solar panels... can't cut it.
You need... I've got 8 bio-reactors. 8! Trying to power this whole sum-bitch, and it's all off of Spadefish,
*giggling* Pretty much just exclusively Spadefish, uh, because they're pretty high, uh, in their energy output. And I've got 8 of them together, but that's not enough...
What I did... And that's why I went to get the nuclear reactor, and that's why we started in the grand reef, and that's why, we're over here,
935 meters below sea level.
Which is pretty frickin' far.
SO! With all that said, the next step that I'm gonna do in the next episode actually involves... pressure compensators, but the -new- style of pressure compensator.
Which I've had in my inventory, they're just generic pressure compensators and they're made... in the uh. The modification station, because they're originally made for the Seamoth, and they allow them to go down, but.
That only allows it to go down 300 meters. To get 'em to go farther, you need to upgrade it... to MK2, and MK3... in the... uh, modification station.
So, that is the next step in this journey, but unfortunately I'm all outta time.
And here are the lovely exosuits- I'll give you a little teaser, I'll jump in the exosuit so you can see, It's actually fully working!
Like, it- it's fully animated... not -fully- animated, but it's run by a power cell, um...
There's no way to craft it right now. So the only way to get it is to spawn it in... uh, but it does have an upgrade panel over here, where I have, the generic version of the pressure compensator,
because its base depth... is, uh, 900 meters. But we're just below 900 meters, so to even get it to survive I had to put the generic version of it in there.
So it, it- it's basically just... it's an exosuit! It walks around, you walky-walky, you jumpy with the thrust.
It doesn't have any swimming capability, it literally just falls and lands on the sea floor, and then it walks around. Which is why it's prefect for exploring this deeper part... once I get the upgrades in here.
So, we're gonna get to that, in the next episode. Not in this one, because I do not have enough time, and I'm not ready to go down there just yet.
But it's gonna be terrifying because next time... I'm just gonna do the upgrades, I'm gonna put the upgrades in here, and then I'm gonna leap off!
I'm gonna leap off the precipice, and I'm just gonna fall! If it's below 1700 meters down there, I'm fucked!
So we have that to look forward to. But either way-
Thank you everybody so much for watching... I don't know how this is gonna go in the next episode, but we're gonna see.
So thank you again everybody, and wish me the best o' luck, 'cause... I'm gonna need it.
So, thanks again... And as always, I will see you... In the next video!
Buh-Bye!
♪ Outro theme ♪